what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are we're wrapping up Hal
Jordan of the Green Lantern Corps here's
a funny thing this is it this is the end
of Hal Jordan the Green Lantern Corps in
DC we were at least I'm pretty sure it
is I it's the final issue for what I
understand what they're doing is they're
combining house run to the Green Lantern
Corps with green lanterns and so going
forward this is gonna be the new story
which is kind of interesting because as
I understand it Doomsday Clock was
supposed to have been done by now or
within the next month or two and it's
not they had they've kind of had to
extend it out in order to make make time
for the art which I don't care Gary
Frank is amazing artist I'll wait until
the end of time to see the end of that
story so the day I died it's the end of
that story if it means Gary Frank will
keep drawing Carrie Frank take as much
time as you need man dude your art is
amazing but uh but nonetheless so so
basically this is the end of Hal Jordan
the Green Lantern Corps and so happily
this is called the last charge of the
Green Lantern's which i think is an
amazing name which is kind of cool
because what this does is it kind of
picks up with a little bit of a
narrative of sorts it really picks up
with the nature of the Green Lantern
Corps from the perspective of tomar -
and it's not the most significant thing
but it is kind of cool because what
tomar - basically says here is like when
he was younger he watched his father as
a green lantern and and it was it was
all inspiring and so it's home r2 giving
us this bit of an explanation what we
know is it of course his father died and
Tamar - took his place you know and and
with tomar - becoming a new Green
Lantern ultimately he was basically
dissuade by his father's death you know
for him it was crushing because it was
like okay where's the justice here like
where where's where's the response to my
father being killed you know and that's
one of the things that kind of drives
his characters what he's been doing so
far is that in his mind the man who
killed his father is still alive his
father's dead but this man still alive
apparently he was worthy of a second
chance well worthy according to who but
who decided with an absolute certainty
this guy deserves a second chance and
whoever whoever said that was wrong and
so in turn tomar - killed that guy of
course after having taken over the
mantle of the dark stars and and that's
what kind of leads us to the current
moment now the big thing about this is
that Jon Stewart's initial response is
we have to defeat the start at the dark
stars without killing them we have to
show the world or show the universe that
justice can be served without murdering
people and you know whether it's
justified or unjustified but here's the
funny thing when it comes to
head-to-head confrontations like this
wars in this capacity are won by those
who are willing to do what the others
want - armies who were even in power
fighting against each other it'll come
down to which ones ever you know
whichever ones willing to do what the
other ones not you know whoever is
willing to push the limits go to the
ends of the
and and basically do what needs to be
done and so in a lot of ways John
Stewart is handicapping his own team
he's handy having the Green Lantern's
behind saying look you can't kill the
dark stars we have to change their
hearts and minds and while that's
admirable at the end of the day it
really seems kind of pointless because
how can he change the mind of a person
who's held in on revenge the one thing
they want is the one thing you're
denying them and so it's interesting you
know in this situation so while all this
conversations going on it's kind of a
funny little tidbit here while all this
conversations going on Hector Hammond is
trying to make everybody happy and he's
doing it by like modifying how they see
everything and first through it like a
birthday party and then they're like
etta at a game and like a baseball game
who the hell goes to baseball games
anymore and then there are then they're
all on the beach which is kind of funny
and it's just like like he's just making
him jump through all these different
things finally they tell him to call it
off but it's kind of funny like I like
Don like Hektor him and now like I want
to see more of that kind of Hector
Hammond for those of you guys who are
new to comics this is a kind of thing
that changes people like like people
will go through and they'll read carries
off I've seen it for years and years and
years years people will go through and
they'll read characters and won't really
care about them and then like a thing
will happen and fans will be like you
know what I like that guy now and like
though like that person you know be I
love Carol Danvers now or I hate Carol
Danvers now or something like that
though they'll be on this position we're
like though they're like their view of
that character will change because of
like one thing because of one instance
of how it's written and so it's kind of
cool and it's kind of funny but
nonetheless with the Green Lantern's
facing off against the dark stars this
is really more of a repeat of the early
stages of the Sinestro Corps award for
those of you guys who remember that when
the Green Lantern's were not authorized
to kill they were basically running and
dodging all the time they were
constantly in a state of retreat because
the Sinestro Corps were not limited by
the bounds of killing they kill Green
Lantern's everywhere they found him and
so anytime a Green Lantern ran into a
member of the Sinestro Corps or multiple
members they would basically take
potshots and they would they would they
would date hightail it out of there and
if the Sinestro Corps was chasing after
then they would just play retreat or
they would play defense until they got
to a larger number of Green Lantern's
finned off as best they could and get
out of there it wasn't until the Green
Lantern's were allowed to kill till the
battle became more even as it was it's a
really interesting situation because
when you have these dark stars what
makes them so difficult what makes them
so deadly here is the fact that they can
teleport they teleport around also keep
in mind that while they all do have
their own individual perceptions that
their tactical capabilities are all
leaked telepathically by the controllers
which in turn are used by by tomar - and
so what this means is that he's kind of
like a one-man army right
he's kind of directing all these members
who are all basically at hamat ons and
in turn like they're launching all these
different strike attacks at the ethic
Green Lanterns they're all you know
using this this massive coordinated
attack and then teleporting in and out
and it makes them almost impossible to
catch and so this is a whole new kettle
of beans because for the most part it is
you know you got like Orion on this
little scooter thing you know his little
scooter thing even of course you've got
like General Zod here and there's a lot
of restraint that's being orchestrated
because it's basically a battle on two
fronts you've got you know a massive
number of the dark stars who are facing
off against like Hal Jordan and Orion in
Colorado and Gardner and those guys and
then you've got the dark stars who are
back at Mogo attacking the headquarters
and so it's it's cool to see this unfold
because you're talking about people
coming together who would normally never
fight together and seeing General Zod
fight alongside the the land to like
fight alongside arkillo of the Sinestro
Corps and the other Green Lantern's and
then of course like like Orion is
actually pretty cool because you would
never really see anything like this now
of course with regards to to General Zod
himself and even with the Guardians of
the Universe stepping in by and large
their power is not really enough to stop
the dark stars because the dark stars
were able to overpower the controllers
who of course are formidable in and of
themselves but again having a hive mind
being able to strategically plan out
entire events and knowing where every
other member of the dark stars are in
striking in a coordinated fashion makes
things incredibly difficult because you
gotta remember this is basically a
battle on the spot for for the Green
Lantern's it's just kind of the dark
stars are suddenly here and so it's not
like they had a huge amount of time to
plan out how they're going to co to
strategically attack and even if they
did there's no guarantee it would have
gone to form because they're not all
linked to the same mind and so that's
one of the things that Orion points out
here we're way out of our league like we
can't fight an enemy like this head-on
because we're getting absolutely
decimated by these guys they're just too
tight too cold too strategic there's
nothing we can do here and so how John
is kind of like the Trojan horse right
like how Jordan grabs Hector Hector
Hammond and they take off to the
controller's where their minds are
linked and the idea of Hector Hammond is
to sever the telepathic link and it's
kind of funny because Venditti plays on
this idea that it's going to be like an
almost insurmountable task and it's
going to be wildly difficult to achieve
and so when he tells Hector ham and
here's what I need you to do Petra ham
is like okay done and and then that's
there so I was like okay so we've
achieved this
okay what's what's what's the next thing
that we do now and it kind of Kansa Hal
Jordan by surprise he's kind of like
well I mean I didn't really expect it to
be
easy but that's cool so so this
basically sends kind of a psychic shock
through the minds of all the dark stars
and even if it only grants a brief
moment of reprieve that's all the Green
Lantern's need to swoop in and try to
take out the entire dark star group in
one fell swoop now of course it doesn't
quite work as planned because even when
you're talking about the dark stars
losing their telepathic powers there's
still very very very dangerous in their
own right at this moment right now
they're more akin to the old you know
old dark stars from like the 1990s the
original iteration of the group but for
this purpose they're still pretty
capable now the other half of this is
that they are still teleporting around
in rapid fashion and that's one of the
other things what Jon Stewart had done
and she kind of orchestrated this
two-pronged attack the first was to cut
off their telepathic connection using
Hal Jordan and the second one was to use
a teleportation disrupter he'd built to
block off their ability to teleport
around and so that's what ends up
happening here tomar - kinda starts
talking trash jumps in front of Hal
Jordan and he can't teleport away
h-how'd Rinna gets the better of him
gets the attack and that's when they
start to panic and that's what they have
to get out of there at the same time Jon
Stewart shows up with a full contingent
of the Green Lantern's and says okay now
it's time for us to start taking the
fight to the dark stars
this is classic Green Lantern's
storytelling it's one of the coolest
things that you know that you get to see
one of these are the Green Lantern's and
what makes them interesting in a lot of
ways at Marvel Lux is there's no like
disheveled mess you go and look at the
cosmic landscape in Marvel Comics you
walk into a comic book stories you say
okay I want to read cosmic Marvel it's
like we'll take your pick you've got
guardians of the galaxy you've got Nova
you've got quasar you've got any number
of the other things who are out there
like you've got all these these huge
expansive things you've got the Thanos
book you got Silver Surfer you got all
this stuff with DC it's not nearly that
complicated with DC you don't have to
worry about the Eternals you know neil
gaiman's Eternals or anything like that
it's just Green Lantern's done super
simple and doing that basically allows a
writer to consolidate into focus
strictly on the Green Lantern's with
whatever it is they happen to be
fighting against and whoever it is they
want to invoke keep things simple and
action-packed at the same time and it
works incredibly well and so having
these guys face off against each other
like this ultimately what it ends up
doing is it comes down to how to earn
himself because in reality again the
plan of Jon Stewart's kind of failed and
that's one of the failings of Jon
Stewart is is this belief that well we
have to make sure that we stay the
course we have to make sure we do the
right thing and while that's admirable
admiration does not win wars what wins
Wars is doing what needs to be done and
Jon Stewart at the end of the day is not
doing what needs to be done
they truly want to win they have to kill
all the dark stars to cut them off
entirely in response to this how Jordan
kind of picks up the slack and says well
then fine because I'm basically walking
talking willpower I'll channel that
directly into the dark stars themselves
and so where he faces off directly
against home r2 he's able to hold his
own I meet Omar too is by no means a
slouch but the funny thing about this is
that in this fight between the two tomar
two really keeps asking the question how
can you be okay with the fact that your
dad died like that you know because it
was essentially negligence it was a it
was an aircraft that wasn't ready to fly
it took off it blew up the most
predictable scenario happened and your
pop sign in the process how can you be
okay with this and how Jordans response
was well because it's made me who I am
if everything that's ever happened to me
in my life and everything I've ever said
and ever done and has ever been done to
me and has ever been said to me
has led me to this place right now it
couldn't have been that bad because this
made me the hero that I am but for tomar
too he's driven by Greer he's driven by
grief and driven by rage and revenge and
all these different things has sort of
come together to coalesce and turn him
into a Dark Star and so in response to
this you know Hal Jordan is for the most
part able to defeat him he's able to
take him out because again at the end of
the day tomar 2 is no he's no Hal Jordan
and so is when this is going on suddenly
you have General Zod who steps up and
this is why I like Zod so much because
odds like okay so there's basically
those who seek victory and those who are
too weak to find it and so in this
instance he says like I'm just gonna
i'ma start killing people but yeah
that's what this is now these guys are
gonna keep on fighting and fighting and
fighting until they win they'll fight to
the last man and so if what they want to
do is fight to the last man
then I'll just help them along the way
and so in the process who goes to kill
one of the dark stars Jon Stewart Guy
Gardner Kyle Rayner step in and say do
not kill him we have to find a better
way but house werden again steps in
saves the day how Jordan basically ends
up taking like all the willpower that
makes him who he is and handling it
directly into the dark stars energy
source and then by doing that basically
imbues like like imbues all of them with
willpower now the reason why he does
this is because previously Guy Gardner
had told him look I used willpower in
order to overcome my Dark Star suit and
how Jordan is nothing if not
strategically intelligent he's not the
sharpest tool in the shed
you're never gonna see how Jordan go to
MIT he's just too dumb but with regards
to like military combat training and
with regards to like experience and
being out there the guy's got it where
it counts and so putting two and two
together he literally channels willpower
through their energy source and men
basically overrides the darkstar
technology and so with the Dark Star
technology being overridden it's
removing a Red Lantern ring the person
returns to their normal self and Tamar -
is literally just driven by like grief
at this point he just kind of I can't
believe I did all this today that I went
a rampage like this and did all these
different things and in a moment when
General Zod goes to try to kill him
what's home are two ends up doing is
actually killing himself he ends his own
life and so he's just kind of like I'm
beyond redemption there's nothing I can
do to make up for this and so he took
the only step he felt he could buy
basically ending his own life and so in
this moment what is up happening is of
course his ring races off to go find a
replacement the war is basically done
the dark stars are gone the sources
ended the other there really doesn't
seem to be any indication they'll make
their return and of course this leads
basically into the epilogue and it's a
cool thing because remember ever since
edge of oblivion
the Green Lantern number has been
reduced to almost zero when you had this
massive Green Lantern Corps there was
basically thrust all the way to the very
beginnings of the universe and had to
work their way back to the modern day as
so many of them were lost in the process
now in reality it was a way for DC to
thin the herd it was away for D it was
it was like DC's version of decimation
for the x-men and get rid of the
lanterns that just didn't really have a
plot pointer they really couldn't do
anything with and then keep the ones
that everybody loved along with a few
others just to bolster the ranks and
then send the group back out into the
main DC universe at the beginning of
rebirth and so with this whole thing
happening what they need are more Green
Lantern's and so that's why John Stewart
basically ends up you know kind of
beginning the ceremony which basically
sees the creation of a whole new host of
rings being sent out directly into the
universe itself and seeking out a whole
new host of Green Lantern's and so it's
basically everything returning back to
the status quo it's almost like Robert
Van Diddy's way of saying okay let's
transition everything back to right
before Jeff John started Green Lantern
we have this vast number of lanterns and
we can basically kind of go through and
start crafting whole new stories and so
at the tail end of this we get to see
the return of a familiar character we
get to see how Jordan returning to earth
traveling to Coast City and meeting
Carroll fares and this is actually
pretty exciting this is a big deal we
haven't seen her for a very long time
and so it's cool because there's a lot
of questions that come out of this will
she return to being a star sapphire is
she just going to be the love interest
of Hal Jordan are they gonna have a life
together pop out a couple kids like we
really don't know what direction things
are gonna go in with regards to the two
of them in this comic book line but I'm
very very excited to find out but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
too comments explained make sure you
guys at the sub button to become part of
the rob4 if you guys enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all
later peace
[Music]